[Music]
as a really heartbreaking study but asks
Americans
how many close friends do you have you
can call on in the crisis and when they
started doing it decades ago the most
common answer was five today the most
common answer is none it's not the
average but it's the most common answer
and I thought a lot about that in so
many of the places I've been in the
United States interviewed it got to know
an incredible man call professor John
Cacioppo he's a world expert on
loneliness is at the University of
Chicago and professor Cacioppo explained
to me you know if you think about the
circumstances where human beings evolved
right we evolved the reason why you're
able to watch this through your laptop
or wherever you're watching it the
reason why we exist is because our
ancestors on the savannahs of Africa
were really good at one thing they
weren't bigger than the animals they
took down but they were much better at
cooperating than them if we human
instinct human beings have is to be part
of a cooperative tribe right bees need a
hive humans need a tribe and if you
think about the circumstances where
human beings evolved if he was separated
from the group you would become
depressed and anxious for an incredibly
good reason you were in terrible danger
you were probably about to die those are
the instincts we still have yet we've
told ourselves a story that we can live
without tribes we are the first human
beings ever to try to live without
communities to imagine that like some
cowboy on the horizon and even the
Cowboys didn't do it this way we can
live alone we can be alone but that's
not the species we are and it's causing
and professor Cassio posed proven that
this loneliness epidemic is one of the
key causes of the epidemic of depression
and anxiety that we have across our
society and I was reassured to find what
who is acted on that he's tried to find
an antidepressant for the loneliness
crisis I met an incredible man
one of the heroes of my book lost
connections called Sam ever in turn
Sam's a doctor in East London one of the
poorest parts of East London actually
where I lived for many years and Sam was
really uncomfortable because he had
loads of patients coming to him who were
depressed and anxious and he had been
told in his training even though he knew
the science was much more sophisticated
than this to tell people well you feel
this way because you got a chemical
imbalance in your brain and just give
them drugs like me Sam is not
- those drugs he's in favor of them but
I just thought this is this is not
enough
this isn't solving the reason why these
people are depressed and anxious he
could see how lonely and cutoff they
were so he pioneered a different
approach and I'll tell about it through
one of the patients of his that I got to
know Wilma called Lisa Cunningham came
to Sam Lisa had been shut away in her
home for seven years crippling anxiety
and depression she came to Sam Sam said
don't really psycho and give me the
drugs whatever you need I'm also going
to prescribe something different I'm
going to prescribe for you to take part
in a group there was an area behind the
doctor surgery that was known as dog
crap alley right gives a sense what it's
like they didn't use the word crap I
mean be polite it just area scrubland
and what Sam said is what I'd like you
to do is twice a week I'd like you to
meet with a group of other depressed
anxious people will turn out and support
ya and I'd like you to just turn this
into something beautiful the first
meeting Lisa was literally physically
sick with anxiety so many of the other
people there were shaking and they
started talking to each other they
didn't know anything about gardening
they were inner-city people from from
East London as the weeks and months and
then years went by they taught
themselves gardening they had something
to talk about that wasn't how terrible
they felt they could reconnect with the
natural world there's incredible
evidence that interacting with the
natural world is one of the most
powerful natural antidepressants we have
and as human beings do when we're in
groups they started to solve each
other's problems there was a guy in the
group who was sleeping on the night bus
Lisa thought well of course you're
depressed you're sleeping on a bus she's
outraged hire some other people in the
group started pressuring the local
authorities to get him housing they
succeeded it was the first thing they
done for someone else in years it made
them feel better than doing anything for
themselves and the way Lisa put it to me
as the flowers began to bloom they began
to bloom there was a study in Norway
which was part of a growing body of
research of a very similar program that
found it was more than twice as
effective as chemical antidepressants I
think for an obvious reason it's dealing
with the reasons why they were so
depressed and anxious in the first place
everywhere I went in the world I found
the most effective strategies with
depression and anxiety
were the places that were dealing with
these deeper causes
[Music]
you